so i i think when people hear that right
where you're going to take the time 100
and you're going to uh
put it on television talk through a
little bit how you think about
uh a startup or an incumbent who
couldn't
you know have that conversation strike a
deal like that they would say oh if we
want to do something we're just going to
stream it on the internet
right so that's kind of one option the
second is on television and so
is it a uh attraction because of the
audience size
is it an attraction because of the
partner they're like why go to
television versus digital
i think it's a prime example of these
situations
so we do a lot of digital distribution
and we have a lot of success you know we
do the time 100 talks which we launched
in q2
not as a virtual event as a television
show we do it every week
and every week hundreds of thousands of
people actually tune in to watch it
and then ultimately it gets clipped and
it gets millions of views as we put it
through our ecosystem
um the ability to get quickly into the
network world is
is uh i mean no matter how much it's
transitioning today
uh it's still gigantic right on every
level
and still where a lot of eyeballs are
today on every level and so
there is a prestige to being able to do
something of that
i think that what a lot of people tend
to say when they look at
sort of evolution is is um forget
forget targeting this person let's
target this audience like this is
useless
or this was the old let's go to the new
and i'm simply saying like
you can't discount anything like half of
the time 100 this year is going to be
digitized
right and it's going to be streamed over
our own site and over twitter
and through those feeds and a portion of
it is going to be broadcast
right and i don't think like a brand
like ours should ever say either or like
we should play in all the different
areas
um i learned quickly when i was at wired
a really interesting um
reality of getting talent uh
to to speak at events
and i remember
we had uh chris sacca at the
wired business conference god i want to
say
maybe in 2010 i might be wrong on the
year
but he made a comment to us to maya
drey's news now with me at times she's
amazing but she
he made a comment about about he didn't
he didn't come and speak to the wired
business conference for the 400 people
that were in the room
right like there were great 400 people
that we curated
he he spoke at the wired business
conference for the distribution that the
wired brand gave him
to the entire ecosystem that was outside
the room
and i think that to any small brand
like what you want to think about is is
like there's one value to speaking to
your audience but if you don't have the
distribution to push it out
there's only so much influence and
impact that you can ultimately have
and um you know like i do think that
there's huge value you know we take the
time to talks and not only do we stream
it on our site but we stream it live
over
twitter and facebook and linkedin by
three very big communities for us
so that way we are maximizing what that
reaches digitally
speaking of digitally time is
already going through this transition uh
you have
drastically grown the digital revenue is
there a world where
it is 100 digital right and kind of you
do all the things that you do today
just bigger better there's more revenue
channels but
the legacy stuff uh kind of just erodes
away not because you guys wanted to but
just that the trends forced that to
happen
i i don't know i mean here i'll here's
what i would say
is um as it relates to marketing revenue
time is never going to be anything less
than a digital
first marketing revenue sort of
organization however
print um is still a very large consumer
revenue base for us
and you know what was interesting and
what we found was was
we had our internal projections as to
what we could do as it relates to print
revenue
and uh in q2 and we grew print revenue
six percent against
the projections that we had so like in
the most challenging quarter
we found that there still was a large
consumer demand for print
and you know what i would say is is this
think about horses for a second i bet
you you never thought you'd talk about
horses on this podcast
right but like back
prior to trains or cars
right like horses were mass
transportation right like if you think
about did you ever play the oregon trail
game
like growing up like how'd they get
across the country
horses right but then trains came around
and what happened to trains uh what
happened to the horses when trains came
around they became vocal transportation
right
and then cars came around and what
happened to the horses
they didn't go extinct they just came
relegated to two very specific niche
audiences
gamblers right
you can see that one coming and and the
afghans right collectors
and i think that print um
is gonna fall along that same spectrum
like i don't think in my lifetime or in
your lifetime
uh print is gonna disappear but i do
think that
the value proposition that it provides
is going to get
continuously defined by the audience
that it wants
and then all print products are going to
have to choose
um are you delivering what the
expectation is of that audience
and so like in the case of time if you
look at it like the
value proposition of time is it sort of
captures living history in the moment
right like the magazine has gotten rid
of and shed
certain things that historically the um
the was uh that the internet is
essentially replaced
right and it goes to bigger thought
leader pieces it goes to bigger sort of
contextual pieces
the goal of print is to see the ongoing
conversation of the internet not to
compete with it
right and then ultimately like if you
look and you'll see very subtle cues
with it like
we're slowly like we increase the paper
stock right make it a slightly better
product right like and you you
think about it from that perspective and
so i think again that
the people who think that like oh print
is dead
well yes in the marketing sense print is
seeing the floor drop
very quickly there's still business
there right but like
from the consumer fronts there's still a
very strong consumer business that's
existing